معنى من امام مقر المجلس الاعلاني
انتخابات في انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح
الزمن شوقي ومن ديار بكر مراس الجزيره
وليد العطار مرحبا بكما وابدا معكي فرح
الزمان
والتحديث لعمليه فرز الاصوات
المستمره حتى اللحظه
نعم في الحقيقه خلاصه استمرار عمليات
الفرز طيله الليل تؤكد اولا نسبه مشاركه
عاليه احتمالات بتوجه لجوله ثانيه واصوات
خارج حاسمه وذلك لان عمليات الفرز وفتح
الصناديق في من القادمه من الخارج والتي
تمت فيها عمليات الاقتراع قبل اسبوع او
اكثر تقريبا ما زالت مستمره لنعرض هنا
محمد اخر النتائج تم حتى الان
فرز تسعه وتسعين بالمئه من الاصوات حتى
الان
مرشح تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان متقدم
على منافسه من المعارضه اردوغان حقق حتى
الان
49.36% مقابل ان كل جدار اولو حقق خمسه
واربعين بالمئه سنان اوغان نسبه 5% تقريبا
هذه
هي التي قد تتسبب بان نتجه نحو جوله ثانيه
او جوله اعاده بعد اسبوعين من الان لان
لكي يحصل احد المرشحين المرشحين على
منصب الرئيس عليه ان يحقق نسبه النصف زائد
واحد هنا في التقسيم المناطق في الحقيقه
محمد يبدو ان كلش دار اولو حقق فوزا في
مناطق الشرق مناطق الجنوب باستثناء شانلي
اورفا مثلا او او مناطق محاذيه لها حقق
ايضا تقدما في مناطق الغرب وفي الوسط تقدم
في انقره في الحقيقه المعارضه استطاعت ان
تكسب في انقره حسمت اصوات انقره مئه
بالمئه من الصناديق تماما فرزها صوتت
انقره لكل جدار اولو بنسبه
47.3% مقابل ان اردوغان 46% فارق نقطه
واحده ولكنه انتصار للمعارضه ولحزب الشعب
الجمهوري
تحديدا وهو يعطيه هذا الامر رمزيه هامه
للغايه تتعلق بانتزاع العاصمه التركيه من
العداله والتنميه وتقدم فيها
اذا ما نظرنا ايضا لاخر النتائج
البرلمانيه يبدو هنا بانه تم فرز 98% من
الاصوات هنا نشمل مناطق الداخل والخارج
معا مناطق الغرب تقدم فيها تحالف الشعب
المعارض بشكل كبير جنوب غرب ايضا يتقدم
فيها كذلك في منطقه الشرق يظهر هنا اللون
البنفسجي وهو الذي يرمز لتحالف العمل
والحريه هذا التحالف المكون من احزاب
يساريه احزاب اشتراكيه احزاب كرديه ما
يعني ان الناخب الكردي صوت في البرلمان
لاحزابه وفي الانتخابات
الرئاسيه صوت لكل دارو اولو اما بالنسبه
انقر كذلك تظهر واحده من مناطق انقره
انقره مقسمه على ثلاث مناطق انتخابيه
واحده منها ملونه باللون الاحمر يعني ان
تحالف الشعب المعارض تقدم فيها وفاز فيها
على
التحالف تحالف الجمهور وعلى حزب العداله
والتنميه ونتحدث هنا عن 13 مقعدا من اصل
سته
وثلاثين هذه اذا اخر الارقام المتعلقه
بالداخل والخارج الخارج ما زال ايضا مستمر
فيما يرتبط بالانتخابات البرلمانيه لذا
على ما يبدو بان الساعات المقبله او
الساعات القليله القادمه ستكون حاسمه
للغايه نتائج الخارج واضح انها مؤثره
كثيرا نتائج اسطنبول ايضا في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه ستنعكس كثيرا على النتائج
وسيكون لكل هذا
تبعاته في الحقيقه على النتيجه المرتبطه
بالبرلمان كذلك ليس فقط بالرئاسه